[Music]
uh
i i do you know who
janice papa is yeah he's a comedian
pappas janice pappas is like kind of a
well-known
okay and i know people yell at me
because i you know brian collins yelled
at me because we we don't know who the
all the comedians are in the biz well
yeah because we didn't even know who uh
al madrigal was yeah i mean you guys
don't even know who elemental looks like
these guys are idiots all right uh this
is uh
this is his take
on the brandon shop thing
so like if you told me
uh
somebody's special was dog [ __ ] right
and i went and told someone else that
that special is dog [ __ ]
right and then it turned out that the
special wasn't dog [ __ ] because a lot of
other people or some people liked it
yeah that wouldn't be a lie because it's
what i heard from you of course so all
he had to prove was that he heard it
from someone
and that he said what he had heard
you know from that person
and that's what he did
that's what he did
okay that would be like you
telling me the gringo poppy special
is not
is is is not
close
to a chris rock special and i would
repeat that and then someone would come
and say hey i really enjoyed the gringo
poppy and then i would say
when i told it to the fbi i had heard
that it was [ __ ] hammered dog [ __ ]
i'm talking about frozen dog [ __ ] that
had been stomped out on the floor by
another feral animal who
contemplated eating it but it tasted so
toxic that they didn't even eat it
you know it's bad when comics are
breaking their comedic oath of defending
each other to go after him and i think
that a lot of these comics should be
thanking bobby lee and i'll tell you why
because they're the ones bobby this
whole bobby lee situation is the ones
that kind of opened the door when now
comics can criticize brandon shaw and be
like but it's because of what he did to
bobby lee it's not because he's not
extremely hilarious yeah it it it really
did [ __ ] make it open season on shop
yeah
which you know i think a lot of comics
probably wanted to do that but
um
yeah i don't know who jana's pop is by
the way but he's 100 right